play the board not me patience oh Yeller
Checkmate hey guys yup we got exposure
Daniel Park
bad day to go to the park I guess that's
a custom job I don't think this is the
end game
my internet has passed away let's see if
we can't bring that back to life
time is my stay seated the hell is this
you will die today unless you do exactly
as you're told
it's military pressure sensitive two
floors up Bankers hedge fund Crooks I
want you to Rob them do I have your
attention now Orlando or should I call
you Red Knight that was your hacker
handle wasn't it I've been out of the
game a long time now I want to own the
owners you want your servers you're
crazy if I get caught I'm facing 20.
time for the confession
my name is Orlando fryer I am the person
responsible for the bombing in the park
and Hudson Towers
you got a family it won't be the first
cycle with kids I just want to weigh our
option before we orphan his baby it's
about to get a whole lot hotter
you can't nobody
ain't a bummer get her eye on this
coyote I'm in position
building wired to blow up maybe
Orlando's a patsy tick tock tick tock
tick tock tick tock SWAT prep for
assault code red all hands on deck
foreign
[Music]